now to the fight between President Trump
and Twitter that escalated overnight as
we mentioned the company flagged a
presidential tweet about demonstrators
in Minneapolis this happened hours after
mr. Trump signed an executive order
targeting Twitter and other social media
platforms a Twitter spokesman told CBS
News all we have to say about the
response to the president overnight is
in the tweet thread Paula Reid is at the
White House Paula how does the president
justify this order
good morning Anthony the president
claims that Twitter a private company is
trying to censor him and he wants to use
his power as president to crack down but
only Congress has the power to curtail
Twitter's legal protections what I think
we can say is we're going to regulate
the executive order targets liability
protections which shield companies from
being sued for most of the content
posted to their sites the move came 2
days after Twitter for the first time
added warnings to two of the president's
tweets inviting readers to get the facts
if it were legal and were able to be
legally shut down I would do it but the
president does not intend to stop
tweeting and has done so dozens of times
since being flagged on Tuesday there's
nothing I'd rather do than get rid of my
whole Twitter account but I'm able to
get to I guess 186 million people when
you add up all the different accounts
and and Facebook and Instagram but an
executive order cannot change federal
law legal experts say this move is
effectively toothless after the
announcement social media companies
defended their platforms in a statement
Facebook warned this would penalize
companies that choose to allow
controversial speech and encourage
platforms to censor anything that might
offend anyone and Twitter called it a
reactionary and politicized approach to
a landmark law that would threaten the
future of online speech and internet
freedoms House Speaker Nancy Pelosi said
the order is just meant to divert
attention from the devastation brought
by kovin 19 I see
as a distraction from what is the
challenge at hand which is to save lives
today he will try to divert attention to
China the president says he will
announce new action against China after
they pass national security laws meant
to curb freedoms in Hong Kong Tony all
right